这个雪纺呢 这个原价79的
现在放福利给你们39
长得很这个
看呗 这个裙子长得很
但它很舒服
维持感很好
来这个裙 胸围
胸围102120
来这个裙长
140了
裙长140
来这个30 不对 39
扣个2 这个原价79的
后面有个隐形拉链
这样的一个
上面是一个蕾丝
上面是拼接蕾丝的一个背心
牙子一个雪纺一个裙
原价79的
现在给你们29块
29 29 扣个2
29 扣个2
这个呢
哪一块
30弹
拿这一块
这个牌
三额 三额
就是距按着的
这一块
来
也就掉下来了
那么这几条
真的是配 highly
好
还得一个小时
又得一天
还一个小时就熬过去了
我的妈呀
这天天日子怎么过呀
这天天的
度秒如年的都是
来这一款
这个是一个
这个是个学纺
学纺的样面的要的
滑溜溜的这一款小外套
原价39的
现在19了都
修口和底下边边上
都是这种松紧的
来前面这个大拉链
胸围
胸围是126134
来这个一层
一层61
终于又熬了一天
我的妈呀
可难熬死了
1919扣3扣3
19扣319扣3
小孩天天在家吃外卖
没有
哪能老吃外卖
那咋行
我老二在家
放假了
他俩在家
天天在家里玩
老二会做饭
老二在家呢
来这一款
早几天去到外婆家了
然后昨天
那个昨天
那个那个田志愿又回来了
来这一款
这个是一个迷彩
迷彩的一个裤
全送你全送你
小玩也可以学习了
他俩合不来
两个人在一起经常打架
说不两句话就可以打起来了
要来这个两边有协杀口袋的
这一块
这个是全棉100m吗
这个牌子
年100年100的
来这个腰围
腰围的话
64能拉伸
腿围
腿围118120
当场37
护肠98
来这个39扣8
我儿子会烧饭
烧炖米饭
然后炒西瓜丝炒蛋
还会煮泡面
就这些
小的也学做饭了
到时候没人给他烧饭了
自己弄
来这一款
这个是
这个是一个
真正的一个打碟
来尺寸量一下
看洗标还在不
检标了
没标了
人棉辉煌的
胸围96120
长度55
不弄就得天天吃外卖
就是的
他喜欢吃泡面
我不让他吃
一天三顿泡面
为什么他都不够
来这个
这个1919扣个5
他喜欢吃那个
那个什么
米粉
我的妈呀
天天吃米粉
昨晚上刚吃了
今天早上又要吃泡面
我没让他吃
昨晚上刚吃了
这个米粉
米粉
拉面
什么泡面
为什么这些他天天吃不够
还有什么螺蛳粉那些
我的妈呀
来这一款
这是一个粉色粉色的这一条裤
两边也写了阿口袋的
这个好像裤了过了好几条了
腰围六十六六十八
六十六六十八
九块
九块扣八
九块九块扣个八
这个
这个是一个白色
这个是白色的
XS
这一条裤
这有五个颜色的这一条裤
裤底后面是有一个小纽扣
有个小纽扣的
腰尾
腰尾60到70的腰
这个60 70
长度好像是
80 93的长度
93的长度
来这个39扣3
60到70的腰
来这个39块扣3扣3
米色
上午过到两条
咖色灰色
然后还有一个黑色
深咖浅咖
五个颜色
五个颜色底
来这个
这个条纹呢
两边有垫肩的一个小西装
两个两边有垫肩一个细胞
来
胸围
胸围98 98 106
98 106
长度455
这个9块
9块扣个5
9块9块扣5扣5
这个不好
这个上面有洞哎
不要了
这有两个洞
来这个给你们送吧
有没有要的
送第3个5
这个袖子上有两个小洞呢
看看
袖子上有个小洞呢
看没
9块
不是不是送第3个5还9块的
有要的我没人要先放一边去
送都没人要了
你看看送都没人要啊
你们
来这个
这个是内销的
内销的不
内销内销
来这个
后面有个隐形拉链
属于一个圆领这一块
背心裙
来
胸围80 84
80 84
长度78
来这个19扣8
扣8扣8
19扣8
来这个L尺码的
来这个U
这个后面有一个小黄点
这个可以当防晒
可以当防晒
可以当尺码的
可以当衬衣都可以
这个我有一件一模一样的
来这一款
看一下这一款
来胸围
胸围120 126
120 126
来这个衣长
前短后长75 80
75 80
这个我留的时候
都39的时候留的了
来这个上面有一个小拨点
给你们9块
看见没有
有个小黄点连这里
9块9块
扣2扣2
9块扣个2
后面有个小黄点连
这个可以当防晒
当衬衣都行
又长又薄又丝滑
很舒服
这个9块9块
不介意的扣2扣2
9块9块
9块
姐妹们员工没有特别折扣吗
没有
没有啥
没有啥折扣
就把那个9给抹去了
就这样子的
来这个有一点多少也得有点
来这个灰色
灰色
灰色的灰色
灰色这个马甲
灰色的这个马甲
然后这个底下的话是
拼接了一层沙子这一块
马甲
胸围胸围的话是94到104
94104来长度
长度71
来这个29扣1
29块扣1扣1
29扣个1
灰色这个还有个黑色的
这个马甲29块扣1扣1
29扣个1
来这个
这个是一个蓝色全棉100
这个原来还有个上午好像过到一个黑色
袖子的话是棉混纺的
身上是全棉
来胸围
胸围112
112130的胸围长度是76
9块扣8
9块扣个8
棉全棉全棉的
袖子的话
是棉混纺
来这个灰色这个上午过来一件灰色那个色黑色有灰色花的
雪纺的一个短袖外搭没有扣没有扣眼来这个9块扣8
这个上午过了一件了
这又出来一个9块
扣8
9块扣个8
来这一块
这个是一个中袖
没有扣没有扣眼一个外搭也是
来
胸围看一下
胸围100能拉是120
100 120来长度
长度63
9块
扣个三
九块扣三
九块扣三扣三
来
这一款
这个是圆领
然后是一个小短袖
来
这一个
袖子是松紧的一个袖口
腰上是有腰带
来
胸围
胸围九十二
九十二一二零
来
长度
长度七十九
来这个
这个是MIK1的
MIK1的这个
三十九
扣个三
圆加五十九的
这个是老款了
给你们三十九块
扣三扣三
纯白色的
三十九扣个三
不少腰带不少
这个腰带
来这个三十九块
扣三扣三
三十九扣个三
扣个三
来这个L吃吗
这个牌子
这个牌
来
来来
来来来 这个是一个带领的一款马甲的
来胸围108116
108116长度76来这个39扣6
39不对这个2929
扣6扣6我把他当上那个摸碎的了来这个29块扣6扣6这一块
29扣个6马甲黑色黑色连带领了一个马甲
来这一款黑色黑色刚刚过到一个军绿色的现在是一个黑色
这样子的来胸围
胸围112134来这个一长
一长65
一长659块扣个我这里有一条粗纱线
这里有一条粗纱线9块9块扣5扣5
9块扣5
来来这个粉色粉色粉色的这一款卫衣新款
上面全是蝴蝶结的你看呗全都是蝴蝶结的这个粉色粉色的
这一款这一款来
胸围108128108128长度长度63长度63来这个39块扣3扣3